hello and welcome to the take with
sophie ridge live at nine here in the
heart of westminster well the dust is
still settling from election results
last week with all eyes on northern
ireland and whether a new executive can
be formed there the dep are refusing to
play ball unless the northern ireland
protocol is scrapped but that could lead
to another almighty bust up with the eu
meanwhile the queen's speech which tells
us the government's priorities for the
years ahead it looked a bit different
this time it only happened yesterday but
there are already calls for more action
on the cost of living when will that
happen well we'll try and find out as we
bring you takes from all sides over the
next 60 minutes i've made clear until we
see that decisive action we won't be
moving
on the political institutions i want
that to happen quickly
we'll speak to the dep leader jeffrey
donaldson who says the northern ireland
protocol must go
government at the moment would use the
great powers that it has to tackle this
head-on
bring forward an emergency budget we
will continue to use all our ingenuity
and compassion
for as long as it takes
and after prince charles left the golden
throne in the lords the commons had a
slightly less resplendent scrap over the
government's plans we'll see what our
viewers panel made of all that uh here
they are well hopefully very soon there
we go there they all are indeed we'll
also be talking about kierstan's big
eight gamble to try and get their view
on that too hello everyone little wave
we're going to come back to you in just
a few moments say thanks for that we'll
also have some other top guests on the
programme including international trade
minister ranal joadina and labour's
thank you debonair as well much more
besides all coming up on the take
[Music]
good evening well as you can tell there
is hardly time to draw breath after
those elections across the country
perhaps the most significant though in
northern ireland sinn fein won the most
votes and the most seats on the assembly
and now usually that means its leader
michelle o'neill becomes first minister
but it's not that simple this time
because under the power sharing
agreements you need the leading unionist
party to agree to form an executive and
take the deputy job now that is the dep
and they say it's a no-go unless the uk
government changes the northern ireland
protocol the part of the brexit deal
that effectively puts the customs border
in the irish sea oh and of course if the
uk scraps a protocol without an
agreement with the eu well then we're
looking at a huge row and possibly a
trade war as well so what does the dp
have to do its leader jeffrey johnson
joins us now live from belfast thank you
so much for
being on the program uh today
you've said that you won't nominate
ministers to you know form a new
executive until your concerns are
resolved about the northern ireland
protocol what exactly do you want to see
happen
well i think it's time now after months
and months of interminable negotiations
between the uk government and the eu
for decisive action uh we've been
patient we've waited and waited and
waited but there's been no outcome from
those negotiations and we heard last
night from liz trust who's leading the
uk negotiating team
that they've rejected the eu's proposals
from last october so there's it appears
there is no basis upon which an
agreement is likely in the short to
medium term and in the absence of such
an agreement we believe that the uk
government should act to protect the uk
internal market and northern ireland's
place within it
so let's be clear about what that would
mean you effectively say the uk
government should unilaterally act
without agreement from the eu
to scrap parts of the deal that they
signed i mean that would be breaking
international law wouldn't it and also
potentially risking a trade war with the
eu
well of course the protocol itself makes
provision for unilateral action where
the protocol is causing harm economic
harm political harm societal harm and it
is evident and the uk government in its
command paper last july stated that the
protocol is harming northern ireland
it's harming our economy it is
undermining political stability here so
i think in those circumstances and in
order to safeguard the belfast or good
friday agreement and the political
institutions the uk government is well
within its rights to act in these
circumstances
do you really trust the uk government
to act as you say boss johnson's been
promising action for months
well i think that uh in terms of the
government
i'm not going to take it uh just on the
basis of words and we did have words
yesterday in the queen's speech but we
need to see action and that's what i
will judge the government by at what
action they're prepared to take to deal
with the real difficulties that this
protocol is causing for northern ireland
so on friday because i want to talk a
little bit about what you're prepared to
do on friday the newly elected northern
ireland assembly will meet to elect a
new speaker now really the assembly
can't function until that happens and it
needs cross-party support to do so will
the dep support that election
well we're waiting to hear from the
government we want to see what the
government has to say
we will meet before friday and decide uh
our course of action in relation to
the proceedings in the assembly on
friday so i'm not in a position to say
right now but we are clear we need
government action
so it seems pretty clear that you're
keeping on the table the fact that you
might not even support a speaker at
being nominated for the assembly i mean
some would say shin fame would say that
you're effectively holding northern
ireland to ransom
well of course sinn fein for three years
prevented not only the election of a
speaker but the appointment of an
executive for three whole years one
thousand forty four days sinn fein
didn't turn up to the executive and the
assembly to do their job so i won't take
any lectures from sinn fein on that
point
but at the same time you know what about
the people in northern ireland who voted
for you many people voted for you to get
go to the northern ireland assembly to
help with lots of issues including the
cost of living crisis and they might say
hang on don't we deserve to have an
assembly that's functioning
well of course they do and i want a
functioning assembly but the assembly
can't function in the absence of a
cross-community consensus and when i
stood before the people with my party in
the election we made clear we wouldn't
be forming an executive until the
protocol issues are dealt with so i have
a mandate to do what i'm doing and i
intend to hold by that mandate
you say you have a mandate but at the
same time the majority of people voted
for parties who accept or people who
accept the northern ireland protocol 54
of the 90 newly elected mlas accept the
protocol so do you really have a mandate
to do this
yes i do because the assembly operates
not on majority rule as uh because when
unionists were in the majority of course
nationals would not accept majority rule
and therefore at the heart of the
belfast agreement is the principle of
power sharing by consensus and there
isn't a consensus at the moment on the
protocol and we need to have that
consensus that is the basis upon which a
government can be formed that is right
that is the core central principle of
the belfast or good friday agreement it
is power sharing by consensus and not a
single unionist uh mla elected to the
assembly last week supports the protocol
and if this situation were reversed does
anyone seriously believe
that nationalism would be ignored that
the nationalist parties would simply be
dismissed of course they wouldn't their
concerns would be addressed and it's
important that unionist concerns are
addressed if we're to have that power
sharing on a cross-community consensus
basis
okay um i want to talk a bit more about
the protocol and the brexit deal because
of it was was obviously negotiated by
boris johnson he told us it was a
brilliant deal
at the time uh and i just want to play
a quick clip of what boris johnson told
me this is december 2019 so
around the time of when it was agreed
let's just listen
there's no question of there being
checks on goods going
nigb or gbni because they're part of if
you look at what the deal is
we're part of the same customs territory
so he said there will be absolutely no
checks there'll be no question of there
being checked on goods going nigb or
gbni
do you think boris johnson didn't
understand what he was signing or do you
think he just wasn't telling the truth
well look i don't know the answer to
that question sophie i think only the
prime minister can answer that but i
can't tell you this that in the house of
commons when these matters were debated
the dup pointed out very clearly to the
prime minister what the protocol would
mean in practice it would mean customs
checks on goods moving between great
britain and northern it would mean
additional costs delays more paperwork
for businesses in northern it would
drive up the cost
for consumers in northern ireland of
goods that have come from great britain
and that has been the case today the
cost of living crisis in northern is
being exacerbated by the fact that it
costs a lot more now to bring goods from
great britain to northern the road
haulage association estimate that the
additional cost of transporting goods as
a result of the protocol is 27 in the
first year of its operation that means
food prices are dearer here in northern
than they are in great britain it means
that consumers households hard-pressed
households at the moment who are facing
higher energy bills are also facing
higher food bills because of the
protocol and that's not acceptable and
that's why we're saying the prime
minister must act if the prime minister
believes that the right that the right
outcome is that there should not be any
checks on goods moving from great
britain to northern then that's the
outcome we all want to see
you also had an exchange with theresa
may uh in the house of commons yesterday
i just want to play her response to you
because she obviously thinks that you
should have signed up to the deal she
had on the table let's listen
i put a deal before this house which
which actually met the requirements of
the good friday agreement
and actually enabled us not to have a
border down the irc
or to have a border between northern
ireland and the republic of ireland
sadly the dup and others across this
house chose to reject that but it was
just such an opportunity for what he
wanted
she's right isn't she there had been a
lot lighter checks under her deal do you
regret not backing it
not at all sophie because of course um
theresa may's deal the backstop would
have put in place a temporary
transitional arrangement whereby for uh
two years after uh the uk had left the
european union all of the united kingdom
would remain in the eu customs union and
the eu single market
after two years great britain alone
would have the right to leave the
customs union on the single market
leaving northern ireland permanently
stuck in both the eu single market and
customs union now
that in all is the protocol is that's a
far worse outcome for northern that
would leave a permanent uh
barrier a border between northern
ireland and great britain we would have
been outside the uk customs union
currently were inside it we would have
been outside the uk internal market
currently we're inside it but the
protocol creates barriers to trade
within the uk internal market so that's
why we need those barriers to remove
that so-called rec border and to put in
place arrangements that protect both the
uk internal market and the eu single
market and we believe there are
pragmatic solutions there that will that
will satisfy everyone's needs but the
protocol certainly doesn't do that okay
if just finally if the government does
take action if you are satisfied on the
protocol and i appreciate that feels
like a long way away it's a big if at
the minute
will you commit to facilitating a sinn
fein first minister by nominating a
deputy
well it's not a matter of facilitating
sinn fein we accept the outcome of the
election it is a matter of facilitating
the formation of an executive and yes we
will nominate our ministers to an
executive because we want to get on with
the business of government and providing
good stable government for northern
ireland but sadly the uh
the long shadow of the protocol is
leaving its mark on politics in northern
ireland at the moment it has created
instability it has undermined the very
delicately balanced arrangements that
were put in place uh through the belfast
and successor agreements that's why we
need this matter dealt with i want to
see stable institutions i want to see
northern ireland prospering that means
uh the protocol has to be dealt with and
decisive action is required
okay thank you very much indeed jeffrey
donaldson there of dp
thank you
well in a moment we'll get reaction
directly from the government but let's
first see what our senior island
correspondent david blevins makes of
that uh david what jumped out to you
from that interview
well i think it is crystal clear sophie
that the dup has no intention of
participating in the election of a first
and deputy first minister at this point
and therefore northern ireland isn't
going to have a government for a while
but there are two things to watch
carefully i think in the coming days
on friday as you pointed out the first
plenary session of the new northern
ireland assembly is due to take place
for the election of a speaker will the
dup participate in that election if not
it will be a signal
that they think this is going to
linger this crisis in fact that will
deepen the crisis because there won't
even be a government in a sort of shadow
form in northern ireland the other thing
to watch for is what sir jeffrey himself
does he has eight days from the northern
ireland election to resign his own seat
as the member of parliament for lagund
valley and occupy the state he's just
been elected to in the northern ireland
assembly again if he chooses not to do
that at this point it will be an
indication that the dup don't expect any
speedy movement from the government on
the protocol
really interesting stuff david always
good to talk thank you very much for
being on the programme this evening
well a little bit later in the program
we're going to of course talk to our
viewers panel find out what they made of
the queen's speech and their interviews
too
talking of which it's time now to get
some reaction from the government so i'm
pleased to say
uh we are now uh joined by our next
guest to talk about that interview with
jeffrey donaldson find out what they're
planning to do about the northern
ireland protocol and of course about the
cost of living as well we're joined uh
now by the minister at the department
for international trade ranil
jayawardene thank you very much for
being with us so we just heard from the
dep's jeffrey donaldson who was pretty
clear that he is prepared to effectively
block the forming of the executive or
the north island assembly until there's
action on the protocol
is he holding people to ransom here
well good evening sophie great to be
with you and as you've just heard as
we've all just heard the current
operation
of the northern ireland protocol is
disrupting that delicate balance in the
belfast agreement and so it's absolutely
right that the government's going to
take action um to protect the peace and
the stability that the people of
northern ireland need and deserve um the
the truth is
we agreed in northern ireland protocol
in good faith and the eu have um pursued
a very legalistic approach to things so
um you know they have confirmed that
they're not going to change their
mandate um in uh its current form uh the
the northern ireland protocol uh is here
to stay in their view and that's
undermining the belfast agreements so
that is why uh we are determined to seek
change
i'm really interested to find out what
action you are planning on taking
because obviously i'm hearing you know
from many people yourself and other
ministers as well that you agree that
something needs to be done
what exactly are you planning on doing
scrapping checks between all checks
between great britain and northern
ireland and the irish sea
stopping customs arrangements stopping
filling out forms and are you prepared
to do that unilaterally because it does
feel as if the eu well they've been very
clear so they don't want to renegotiate
well look no decisions have been taken
on exactly the way forward at this stage
but it's clear to everyone that the
situation is a very serious one and as i
said the eu have said that they are
fixed in uh their position at this
moment in time so it is right that we uh
leave open any action that's necessary
to preserve
stability and peace in northern ireland
the foreign secretary of course is
responsible and you'll have to speak to
her about uh her latest work in this
regard but the truth is we've got to
solve the problems here because some of
the eu's proposals don't no don't just
not fix the problem they actually make
it worse there'd be more paperwork for
businesses and for the people of
northern ireland and the role of the
european court of justice would still
not be addressed and this isn't what uh
people in northern ireland need so
that's why uh nothing's been ruled out
at this stage i mean it feels to me like
you're
just so far away from the eu on this
that you may as well be on different
planets it's very difficult to see an
agreement
being made in the time frame that we're
talking about so are we talking about
unilateral action which could lead as
you know to the eu deciding to put up
tariffs effectively a trade war is that
a price worth paying
well we have spent now something like 16
months trying to find solutions with the
eu with our friends and neighbors we
want to have a strong positive relation
uh relationship with the eu and you know
our command paper make clear that we're
we're absolutely prepared to carry on uh
with the checks on goods that are at
real risk of entering the eu single
market that's the intention of the
northern ireland protocol but the truth
is that two thirds of all the checks the
customs checks around the border the eu
are now being conducted uh on the island
of ireland this isn't right it's
disproportionate it's overly legalistic
and it's got to change so we have worked
hard to make the protocol work we've
spent hundreds of millions of pounds on
the trader support service
and the movement assistance scheme only
last week um though we we have to learn
that the eu is refusing to use that
purpose-built id system that we set up
so
we've tried to make it work
we've negotiated with uh try to find
solutions and uh you know we will
continue to want to seek to
arrive at a positive outcome for
everyone involved but as i say it's
important that no uh nothing is ruled
out at this stage and as is at this
moment in time okay no absolute
decisions have been taken okay a bit of
a sort of rough direction of travel i
think they're emerging now i'm keen to
talk a bit about the cost of living
because in the queen's speech the prime
minister said
that he would be saying more about help
in the coming days this has been changed
it feels today he's saying now that
there'll be more help in the months
ahead so
what exactly is the time frame that
we're talking about here
well um look i think the prime minister
is absolutely right that we will always
continue to do whatever we can to help
people um but it's important to
recognize what we've already done uh
we've provided um all uh people in uh
homes have banned a to d uh with a 150
pound uh tax rebate uh on their council
tax uh we've been providing uh everyone
uh with a salary boost uh through the
national living wage uh the lowest paid
uh workers have been getting a salary
boost and indeed uh others will be
getting a tax cut through the ni
reductions of 330 pound average tax cut
coming later this year for those on
universal credit we've cut the tapering
so they keep more of what they earn
around a thousand pounds extra on
average and we've increased the size of
the household support fund to one
billion pounds so a lot has already been
done but it of course um i understand uh
as much as anyone else that the cost of
living um is something that we've got to
continue to work on and that's why we've
got to grow our way out of this uh
through new trade deals around the world
creating new jobs you say that you know
you understand that more needs to be
done it does feel like there is an
acceptance among many
of your colleagues that this is a huge
crisis for people
people are really really worried and i
think many people are going to be one
wondering about when they can expect a
bit more help boris johnson has been
showing a bit of ankle on this but when
can we expect it do you think it will be
before the summer recess
well um as uh the chance has already
outlined there will be this reduction to
national insurance uh later this year
which will give um
the average person a 330 pound uh
reductions once you put it up to be fair
it's not a tax cut is it and actually to
be honest the more people i speak to in
your party the more people seem to be
saying that you wouldn't see more tax
cuts is that something that we should be
expecting tax cuts
well first of all people on lower
incomes will be paying less national
insurance than they would have done even
before the recent changes which are
there to fund the health service but
actually um yes as a conservative of
course i believe in cutting taxes and
the chancellor has also outlined a
reduction in income tax and due course
but importantly as i say we can't just
um continue um to spend as the labour
party would do spend our way uh or
trying to spend our way out of every
crisis we've got to make sure that we're
growing our economy and that's why we've
got a long-term economic growth
agenda including new trade deals with
countries around the world not only
australia and new zealand the deals
we've already agreed but with india and
with the uh gulf cooperation council
with canada with mexico these are the
plans ahead that will create great new
jobs for people across our united
kingdom okay i just want to uh read a
quote by uh one of your mp colleagues a
backbencher conservative about benjamin
lee anderson
who was in the house of commons bit
earlier now he said
i think you'll see firsthand that
there's not this massive use of food
banks in this country we've got
generation after generation who cannot
cook properly they can't cook a meal
from scratch and they cannot budget
do you agree with mr anderson that there
isn't a massive use for food banks in
the country it's just that we've got
generations who can't cook properly
well uh look i i think probably what
he's be uh what you've quoted is being
taken out of contest what i would say
is that uh food banks are uh you know a
great example of how the british people
support those who are in need of course
as i've said we've been providing
additional support through universal
credit by um improving the amount of
money that people can keep that they
earn um and i i'd observe um that
you know the opportunity to create new
jobs and give people the security of a
pay packet is actually the way forward
and uh i i know that those jobs that are
export-led that are trading with the
world
are actually paid on average seven
percent higher than other jobs in the
economy so this shows that if we get out
there and continue to grow our economy
get people into well-paid jobs uh trade
with countries around the world um we've
already struck deals with something like
70 countries with a a value of something
like 800 billion pounds that's how we're
going to make sure that we're delivering
not only the benefits of brexit but
making sure that everyone uh can live
better lives in the years ahead uh very
quickly uh because i am out of time is
there going to be an emergency budget
as far as i'm aware um the uh the
chancellor and the prime minister are in
long step on this that we will continue
to provide support this was a queen
speech
i'm still not sure is that going to be
an emergency
and the chancellor will of course make
sure that the right support is provided
at the right time
is there going to be an emergency budget
as far as i'm aware the the chancellor
and the prime minister i absolutely are
one and are going to provide the support
uh in the way that we've always done
making sure that um we're creating
schemes like are you hinting at a
network
i genuinely can't work out if you're
hinting at a no or a yes
is it no or
i can't work it out
as far as i'm aware uh the fact that we
have put one billion pounds into
household supports fund that's already
going to local councils demonstrates
we've got support but we'll keep
everything under review right i think i
think that's him to get a no uh okay
thank you very much uh for being on the
program uh today much appreciated well
let's have a quick word now with our
deputy political editor at sam coats now
find out what he made of all that
i think that was a no to an emergency
budget but i'm still slightly confused
well sophie i'm not one often to have a
great deal of sympathy with the
predicament of mps ministers shadow
ministers that come on these shows
shows uh like yours to defend the
government but i do have a tiny bit of
pity for the minister because he's here
very clearly to defend the government he
wants everybody in number 10 to know he
does a sterling job defending the
government the problem is nobody knows
what they're defending and that's
because the position changes so fast
yesterday morning the government weren't
going to offer any more fiscal fire
power more money from the treasury
effectively to help with the cost of
living crisis then in the afternoon
boris johnson hinted that they might but
the treasury appeared to be somewhat
surprised somewhat aghast at the
suggestion of help within days this
afternoon boris johnson wouldn't rule
out an emergency budget something that
michael gove ruled out with funny facial
expressions on the morning tv round and
then this evening i'm starting to get to
the bottom of what's really going on
what we now expect is there probably
will be another package of support
probably
before the summer because i think
ministers by then wouldn't have enough
data about what the next energy price
hike looks like could that include tax
cuts well i'm told nothing is off the
table how on earth do ministers defend
all of that lot given just how quickly
their stories are having to change
yeah interesting yeah well it's good to
have you to sort of slightly unravel
where we are because i'll be honest with
the various different pronunciations
from different uh members of the
government it is quite hard to keep this
is why we need 24 on these channels yeah
exactly quite there you go good to keep
using the job um on the north island
protocol i'm also interested to get your
thoughts i'm jeffrey johnson pretty
clear that he doesn't see himself
trying to
allow this executive to be formed in the
northern london assembly until
unilaterally or not the northern ireland
protocol is got rid of but it feels as
if the uk and the eu are so far apart on
this and what way forward can you say
there is going to be a bust up between
the uk and the eu over the northern line
protocol what i can't tell you sophie is
how far is boris johnson really prepared
to take it now if we push it to the
ultimate extent then as you were saying
in your interview with jeffrey donaldson
that could mean tariffs that could mean
difficulties in trade that could mean
the whole of critical negotiations over
things like the status of gibraltar is
boris johnson willing to allow further
tariffs at a point where his top
priority he tells us is the cost of
living crisis so we will get the bust up
but what will be the consequences and
that's where the cost of living and big
political projects like this over
northern ireland start to really crash
up against each other it really does and
i guess that's going to like as you say
only going to become clear in those
weeks ahead but time it is not on our
side when we're talking about the
formulation of that assembly thank you
very much sam for talking us through all
of that
you're watching the take we are live in
westminster up next we're going to find
out what the most important people our
viewers make of the queen's speech and
more all after this quick break
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
this is the take and it's been quite a
week already we've had kiestarma
promising to quit if he gets a fine over
that curry and beer in durham and the
state opening apartment no less with
prince charles delivering his mother's
queen speech so let's have a quick watch
of the best bits of the week so far and
do look out for michael gove defending
the government over the cost of living
crisis
in his own unique style that's at the
end of our look at the best bits of the
week
as democrats the dup but also the
british government must accept and
respect the democratic outcome of this
election
brinkmanship will not be tolerated where
the north of ireland becomes collateral
damage in a game of chicken with the
european commission i believe in honor
integrity
and the principle that those who make
the laws
must follow them i'm absolutely clear
that no laws were broken but if the
police decide to issue me with a fixed
penalty notice
i would of course
do the right thing
and step down
her majesty's government's priority
is to grow and strengthen the economy
and help ease the cost of living for
families her majesty's government will
level up
opportunity in all parts of the country
and support more people into work we are
staring down the barrel of something we
haven't seen in decades a prime minister
whose response to the crisis was to make
fun of those that were worrying about
inflation
a government of the moment would use the
great powers that it has to tackle this
head-on
bring forward an emergency budget
with a windfall tax we need the
legislative firepower to fix the
underlying problems in energy supply in
housing in infrastructure and in skills
which are driving up costs for families
across the country
and this queen's speech takes those
issues head-on
take a statement that is common sensical
turning it into
uh major capital letters uh big news
story um and in fact when the treasury
quite rightly say calm down
sorry
really really not sure why the treasury
have scouse accents um but they go and
they do
in the world of michael cove well that
was the week so far let's find out now
what people made of all it's time to
speak to our regular panel of viewers
and here they all are thank you so much
for being uh with us just pick up my uh
cue cards there
so i'm keen to talk to you first about
the queen's speech to find out what you
thought of the queen's speech and
secondly uh to talk about kierstama and
whether or not you're bothered by be a
gay or if you're not bothered at all and
what you make of his uh pledge to resign
if he's fined by the police so let's
just
crack on with the panel uh shall we we
can talk to smith thakkar at first now
sweet you're a labour voter you've been
on the panel before it's good to have
you again from lester
what did you make of the queen's speech
good evening sophie thanks for having me
um yeah um from my point of view it was
um an insincere collection of words um
bereft of ideas
uh and much like
tory black brexit policy it was all
waffle um no substance
there you go and pretty uh strong words
there from smeat uh john commerford i'm
wondering if you've got a different
perspective the sort of conservative
uh voter a former mayor as well i
understand former mayor of living kent i
think i'm right i'm saying um what did
you make of the queen's speech do you
agree with swede's assessment
yes i do greatly uh i thought it was
very lackluster there was nothing there
to help those that are struggling with
the cost of living
and you know there's just so much going
on at the moment where people are having
tremendous difficulty paying their bills
especially energy and things like that
and when you hear of ladies
sitting on buses to keep warm that's
absolutely atrocious we're in a
civilized society that should not be
happening yeah we're referring of course
to you know the things that were put to
boris johnson about elderly people
trying to keep uh warm riding on buses i
can see a lot of heads uh nodding there
let's talk to stella next show if uh
stenner stella findlay you you describe
yourself as a liberal um what did you
make of the queen's speech we've heard
about people saying you know there
wasn't enough on the cost of living what
were your main takeaways
uh i think i'm liberal by default sophie
um not really by choice it's just the
best of a bad bunch i think that's quite
an important question
yes so i think so um i i was very
disappointed i thought it was very dull
um it was lovely to see
members of the royal family there
but um the content
was very banal
and i think that the whole
[Music]
show of it could have been much more
imaginative because this was an
opportunity to change the format to some
degree it was already changed by the
queen not being there um but i think it
would have been nice to have seen the
queen so i think that the format as it
was in person could have been the same
but it would have been nice to have had
the queen on zoom perhaps and delivering
the
the queen's speech herself that would
have been a really radical change
certainly um
but why not
right let's talk to ian
uh next shall we uh ian michael jordan
labour voter what's your takeaways from
the queen's speech
well it was a bit like a meringue there
was very little in it uh and i think the
queen was fortunate not to have to give
it goodness knows what prince charles
made of it there was absolutely nothing
and there's a huge crisis brewing and
action really needs to happen
and for the government to say that
people aren't using food banks because
they don't know how to cook goodness
gracious the time will probably come
when people won't be able to afford to
cook because they won't be able to
afford the power to cook it you know
there's an argument for bringing back
british restaurants that functioned
between 1940 and 47 during the during
the war um so
no the queen's speech was
a real disappointment they think we've
had unanimity i think on the queen's
speech rarely for our panel uh probably
we're pointing out it was a conservative
backbencher who made the comments about
uh cooking but you know the point still
stands by mp certainly uh right let's
talk about our next uh topic of
conversation shall we and i'm really
interested to hear what people make of
kirstjammer's um comments because i feel
like it's one of these ones where you
know we talk about an awful lot in
westminster but actually finding out
about what the public make of it i think
is actually really uh worthwhile uh to
do and let's talk to lisa goddard at
fair shall we now lisa you're a labour
voter um what do you make about big
eight if you like what do you think it's
serious are you worried about it at all
or not really
uh i think that i don't think that he
should have had to come forward and say
that he would resign
it should go without saying that you
would resign if you've got a fixed
penalty notice or committed any crime if
you were in charge of the law uh i'm
disappointed more and more when i see
the video of him at the window drinking
uh beer i don't think that's any
different from those in downing street
that were drinking wine uh during their
working lunch
but it wasn't suitcases full of uh
wine and uh singing
whatever time in the middle of the night
i feel a little more disappointed with
with kieran things at the minute i think
that
needs to a little bit more work but more
effort that's interesting as a labour
voter as well but perhaps you know
feeling a bit of frustration in
in the leader of the party at the at the
minute well let's get the perspective of
rob tyler shall we now you're a
conservative voter uh rob you're based
in bolton um do you agree with what
lisa's saying or do you think have you
have a bit more sympathy with uh kierst
dahmer
i don't think that stanley should resign
i don't think that anyone should resign
um beer gate and proud to go to
yesterday's news the yesterday's news
now what i would like to see is our
elected members working together
stopping slinging mother each other the
real issues are going to come in five or
six months time and then the fuel prices
and the food prices and they've got to
be tackled soon it's going to be very
easy to put them to the back of our
minds as summer comes but we need to
give people peace of mind as they're
going to move into what could be a very
cold winter uh dr paul blom do you agree
with that don't um rob doesn't really
care about partygate or beergate what's
your take
yeah um i i i i think be a gate um
he is really something which um has been
blown up by the press uh i think we
should move on from that i don't i don't
think that uh kirsten really should be
resigning i think uh
he made himself a bit of a hostage to
fortune but
really i think it does there's no
equivalence between what he's did and
what was happening in downing street and
partying myself
i just said well just about the queen's
speech i think the one big admission
which no one seems to mention i totally
agree with the cost of living wasn't
mentioned but his climate change which i
think is the biggest emergency face in
this country and there was nothing about
climate change and achieving net zero in
the queen's speech which i think was a
very big admission uh interesting and
they see some nodding from some of our
queen speech commentators agreeing with
that uh point and finally let's talk to
er eroika shall we and what do you make
about being eight do you think that
uh pick
kierstama get my words out this evening
do you think kirsten was right to pledge
to resign
well
if he if he does resign and it's quite
laudable really to
decide to resign
it it won't make any difference to
how boris johnson is proceeding because
boris johnson's going to lumber on
and
that would mean that kierstama bowed out
on a very honorable
you know
guys if you like but but it's not going
to make any difference because i don't
think it's going to make change the
conservative party at all i don't think
that they
they they
that it's not going to make any
difference we'll just lose kierstama and
i can't really see what that achieves
interesting really interesting uh to
talk to you very nuanced views i thought
and in a bit of a variety of views as
well so thanks very much for coming on
the show uh this week
well plenty for labor uh to think about
there and we can speak now to the party
shadow at leader of the house of commons
fangum debonair thank you very much for
being with us uh in the studio uh this
evening i thought was really interesting
actually i don't know if you heard our
panelists uh in talking about kierstama
in this pledge to resign if he has found
uh to have breached the law and to be
given a fine um
do you think that as our last um
panelist said that you know he has
really achieved anything by offering
this resignation
i think what he's achieved is drawn a
contrast between him uh whereby he has
already said he would resign if he was
issued with a fixed penalty notice over
this incident which and it just seems as
one of your other panelists said to be
no comparison with the prime minister
where there is partying on an industrial
scale there is just no comparison
10 downing street during the first
lockdown where there was wine brought in
in suitcase loads and parties and cakes
and karaoke and guests there is no
comparison and i think it is a it's a
real mark of honor and it is the man i
know here to be and that he is offering
to do that right now but i'm also very
confident i really trust in his judgment
i also know that the man's very good
lawyer and i'm pretty sure that uh that
you know he will have also thought long
and hard about what the best thing to do
is for the party for the country but i
know that his instincts are good and
that he works extremely hard and i'm
looking forward to seeing him being
proved to have not committed any
breaches of rules you say that he's a
very good lawyer do you think in that
case he'll have looked at the evidence
and he'll be pretty confident that it's
going to go one way otherwise no i mean
that actually that he's mr rules like
all the way through i mean this this is
a man who's like got the rules
absolutely down i mean he's he's had to
isolate six times because of covert
tests in his own family or acquaintances
he's really painstakingly stuck to the
rules at some personal cost to him in
his family so i'm saying that in in the
sense that he really understands the
rules he really understands the law he
always does he's very good at bail to
explain what the rules mean one thing
that i am still a bit unclear about is
what happens if durham police do exactly
what they did with dominic cummings they
basically say that they think
that the rules were broken but they
don't issue a fine does kirsten resign
then i mean i think if they think that
the rules have been broken then they
they will be issuing a fine but i don't
think the rules have been broken the
case because i think that durham police
have previously said that they don't
issue retrospective fines and they
obviously didn't with dominic cummings
wow so it feels like it's perhaps even
the most likely scenario
i mean you know they i want the police
to do their job i know the police will
be working hard to do a really thorough
and objective and fair job and when that
happens i mean kier has said that he's
very confident because he knows what
he's talking about he knows what
happened that that's not going to happen
but if it does then he would resign i'm
i'm not really going to get into whether
or not there's a difference of emphasis
there because i think that that gets in
the way of the police doing their job
okay we've been talking a lot about
northern ireland on the program today as
well uh jeffrey donaldson the dep leader
effectively saying that they're not
going to enter this power sharing
arrangement until the northern ireland
protocol is scrapped yeah what do you
make of the dep position
well
that's their position i think the key
person here though is boris johnson
because the northern ireland protocol
was his thing he went to negotiate it he
was the one who came out waving it
around saying he'd got a deal he needs
to own it and he also needs to make it
work i'm not saying it's perfect i think
there are things they need to sort out
but this is not statecraft on boris
johnson's part so i think it's left all
parties feeling like they're fed up
frustrated whatever side they're on they
need that sort of leadership to come
from the prime minister we're not seeing
it at the moment i'd really like him to
do that because the last thing we need
in the cost of living crisis sophie is a
trade war with our nearest trading
partners and that's what we're risking
um so you you would like to see
leadership from the prime minister in
what direction what do you want him to
do because they've you know they've
hinted to say that they will
unilaterally get rid of parts of the
brexit deal without the eu agreement if
necessary well i think that's deeply
unhelpful because that's basically
threatening a trade war and we really
can't afford to do that at a time of
stagnant growth and crippling price
rises we really need boris johnson to
show more leadership than that there are
things that he could do now which could
help shift the negotiations if he went
back to the eu and said let's start with
negotiating on vet regulations which
would help deal with some of the border
crossing issues for food and animal
products that would be a start and it
would be a way of getting people back
round the table and saying look we got
to be able to find some common ground
here so whatever happens you don't think
that the uk should do anything without
eu agreement because effectively that
would break international law is that
where you're coming i mean i think
agreements that you know the clues in
the world it actually was boris
johnson's agreement in the first place
now if he can't make this one work he
needs to find a way to make it and make
it amended so that it does work the last
thing we need is no agreement because
that doesn't benefit us it doesn't
benefit british workers doesn't benefit
british businesses it would be a real um
damaging effect on our economy so it's
not good for us but the dep i guess
would argue that you know if
if if he's not going to do anything
without the eu improvement that's
damaging for northern ireland because
they're having to by the brunt of these
checks but that's what negotiations for
isn't it and that's what statesman uh
statesmanlike behaviour that we ought to
be able to expect from our prime
minister that's what we ought to be
seeing at this time okay uh thank you
very much for being on the program
thanks very much uh fangam debonair
there from
labour
this is the take
live in westminster up next we're going
to round up everything we've just heard
and also bring you some pretty
interesting data about labour's
performance in those elections
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
you're watching the take well we've had
lots of takes from all sides this
evening so let's see what our deputy
political editor sam coats
makes of it all uh shall we uh sam what
have you been looking at today
well let's start with your conversation
with thank you about kierstama now a lot
of people a lot of commentators have
suggested that that man pledging to
resign if durham please find him well
that's a brave moon that uh could
basically uh be a bit of a gamble that
plays off that puts him in a solid
position we've got some figures tonight
that suggest it isn't quite that simple
remember durham police are going to take
six to eight weeks to come to their
decision and 54 percent of people
according to yougov say that kierstarma
probably or definitely did break the
rules 21 percent say he probably or
definitely did not why is that important
because it makes bo kierstama's argument
against boris johnson harder because
people might think he's a hypocrite if
54 of people think he'd probably break
the war right let's look at what people
think of the gamble that he took
and whether he should resign 46 say that
he should resign 32 say that he
shouldn't interestingly a higher
proportion of tories think he shouldn't
resign than labor interesting because
actually i think that's what we found on
our panel as well the tories seem to be
a little bit more forgiving than some of
these on the uh cynic might say just
they wanted the obvious knock-on effect
which is that the kierst armor goes
boris johnson will face more pressure to
go right let's have a look at what
you've been looking at at the local
elections because this is really
interesting isn't it right so we have
had lots of rushed hot takes in the
major aftermath uh of the local
elections we're not guilty but some
others are but i thought we'd go back
and have another look at some of the
results and what it tells us and what
we've done is we've picked three
councils bolton kirklees and wakefield
that are broadly speaking areas where
the tories made gains in 2019 and then
three councils milton keynes plymouth
and worthy where they were pretty much
safe tory area so let's look at what
historically before boris johnson was
prime minister the trend was now what
you're seeing here is which party got
the highest share of the vote and by how
much so labour won bolton council
by vote share by by six percentage
points labour won 40 by 14. that's the
historic yeah
traditional states and what happens in
the next year then okay so let's look at
what happened in 2021 you see that
really labor didn't make much progress
in fact it went backwards in some of
these areas but in the local elections
look at this labor actually back to
making progress in these areas both
areas in the north where they lost out
in 2019 and areas in the south where
they were struggling against uh a
traditional tory really interesting so
actually i guess the narrative that
labour aren't making the progress they
need in the red wall well maybe if you
compare it to 2018 but not really if you
look at 2021 at all yeah and so i think
it it it's nuanced but it wasn't a
disaster for labour last thursday
interesting so not an election winning
territory but perhaps doing slightly
better than some of those hot takes on
the red wall would suggest sam thank you
very much for explaining uh all of that
for us always good to talk well
plenty of takes as always here on the
take i really hope that you're going to
join us next week it's always a really
busy show lots of fun to do and plenty
more coming up of course in the next
week
[Music]
you